with great faces Democrats cast this
historic moment as sad sobering
unnecessary on the solemn day and I
recall that the first order of business
for members of Congress is the solemn
act to take an oath to protect and
defend the Constitution of the United
States I will begin by swearing you in
would you call yourself a never Trumper
everyone was in the loop it's been two
months of evidence and acrimony Trump's
supporters with surprises a diplomat
with the story of a smear campaign
another with a warning shot now the
charges to articles of impeachment
against Donald Trump abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress it is an
impeachable offense for the President to
exercise the powers of his public office
to obtain an improper personal benefit
while ignoring or in injuring the
national interest that is exactly what
President Trump did when he solicited
and pressured Ukraine to interfere in
our 2020 presidential election it's not
just how he dealt with Ukraine's
president that's in question but how he
handled the aftermath when he was caught
when the House investigated and opened
an impeachment inquiry president Trump
engaged in unprecedented categorical and
indiscriminate defiance of the
impeachment inquiry next week Democrats
will almost certainly vote to impeach
the president but they failed to
convince a single república impeachment
is the removal of the highest elected
person in this land I don't care if you
think Americans who support President
Trump are deplorable but you do not have
the right to disqualify their vote just
because you do not like president Trump
that argument may well resonate with
weary voters Donald Trump is telling
America this is about
politics not principal driven by an
elite desperate to usurp him from the
start and it is certainly a process born
and bred in Washington it's what people
think away from here that matters next
year though and those vulnerable
Democrats in districts Trump won in 2016
have a real fight on their hands mr.
Trump has his eyes on the Senate a trial
he can help choreograph and win and a
man determined to have the final word
cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington